look at me it's not practical
we cannot believe the weird things some
actors will do to bring their roles to
life
especially the ones that made them sick
something that i don't really get
to do how far would you go for a role
some of these actors ate gross things
some totally ignored hygiene for way too
long
and some were left stuck in some very
unfortunate smelling rooms
it's pretty hard to determine which one
of these is the worst since some of them
are extremely revolting
let's see for ourselves oh yeah all
those banquet scenes seem like a great
time for the harry potter actors who had
oodles of beautiful food in front of
them that they were actually able to eat
it was great the first day but as the
days went on the cast wasn't too keen
since they
didn't actually replace the food and all
of it started rotting
it was further exemplified by the heat
of the lights used for filming and it
became
so bad that the actors and crew could
literally smell the stench wafting out
of the set before even entering
thankfully they decided to switch to
fake food after that very unfortunate
event
there must be a mistake plenty of people
eat raw fish when it's in sushi but it
was a very different experience for
lawrence who had to hold a real
raw fish in her hands and chomp into it
in the hunger games catching fire
we would think it was a prop or somehow
faked but the fish was as real as the
disgusted faces she made off camera
lauren said that it tasted exactly the
same way it smelled
we'll let you guess whether or not it
was bad or good
hint it was bad what's wrong with her
dicaprio definitely earned his oscar for
the revenant based solely on all the
icky things he actually did
these animal carcasses he sleeps in yeah
those were real the grossest thing he
had to do though was definitely eating a
raw bison liver
the props department did provide a fake
one but dicaprio didn't think
it looked convincing enough he said all
the real suffering he did on set helped
his performance
which was incredible to be fair we
probably
would have stuck with the props though
making the revenant was about man's
relationship to the natural world
sophie turner went on quite a journey as
sansa in game of thrones
like many of her male colleagues she
started using much less shampoo so she
looked disheveled when she escaped from
king's landing
turner said that near the end of the
fifth season the production team asked
her not to wash her hair
and this happened for a full two years
until they finally gave her a wig
instead
her hair became so dirty that it was
constantly greasy and itchy
and when they shot scenes with fake
paper snow well that just created a
huge mess on her head since the small
pieces of paper got stuck in the grease
in her hair
i'm sansa stark of winterfell one of
olsen's many kisses with betany became
known as
wait for it snot gate on a particularly
cold day there was an emotional kiss and
someone's nose started to run
quite a bit resulting in a much sloppier
and grosser kiss than anyone would hope
for
betany claims it was olson's fault but
the one division actress has firmly
stated that
it was betany's fault explaining that he
couldn't feel it because of all the
makeup and prosthetics that he wore
his vision
anne hathaway looks pretty disheveled in
the scene in les miserables
the actual fish carcasses that were
surrounding her definitely did their job
in setting the tone
somehow she sang through the stench that
wafted through the room due to the heat
of the lights that were
shining on them she sang the nearly five
minute song about 20 times on set
meaning by the end of it the smell was
probably
unbearable i was trying not to think
what i was doing
winslet was very keen and eager doing
titanic and wanted to be perfect
considering how major the film was it
makes sense
however this also resulted in taking
bathroom breaks in water tanks on the
set
why would she make this choice well
taking a break would disturb the work
since the bathroom breaks would end up
being a half hour long in order to deal
with all the complex costumes
so she took one for the team let's hope
no one used those tanks to drink from
castle black looked super disgusting on
screen and it was just as bad in real
life
the goal was to make the castle look as
cold grungy and dirty as it could get
so they had the set decorators hang raw
meat from the ceilings
oh and real pigs wandering around too
the production team was really happy
with how it looked in the end but
we have a feeling the cast wasn't loving
it quite so much that'd be more of
reality
in the world they're in clark had to eat
a horse hard as daenerys in game of
thrones and
just watching it is super nauseating
while she didn't eat any real horse
hearts
what she did have was pretty awful she
was told that the creation would taste
like gummy bears
but clark said it was more like
congealed jam that tasted like bleach
it was so gross she actually was getting
sick in buckets between takes
the poor actor wound up having to eat 28
of these disgusting creations
probably not her favorite day on set
what you saw was was really what it was
like
shooting it just when we thought he
couldn't get any scruffier
pattinson went full tilt when he played
a dirty bank robber in the film good
time
he decided the best way to prep for the
role was by renting a dirty cheap
basement apartment to live like his
character
he stayed there for two months and
didn't change his clothes to sleep in
his sheets and he didn't open his
curtains while he was there
his neighbors were super freaked out by
the whole thing
we would be too you don't know what i'm
talking about
while the famous sensual peach scene and
call me by your name is merely performed
in the film
the truth is chalamet had actually tried
doing it on his own to see what it was
like it's pretty wild
this movie got pretty weird in this
scene efron is stung by a jellyfish and
thinks the best way to fix it is with
urine
and nicole kidman's character lends him
a hand with it
this is honestly not too tricky of a
stunt to pull off but the team decided
to go full method by having kidman
actually
help efron out the two actors were ready
to go for it but before they actually
shot the scene
the director lee daniels was questioning
whether or not he wanted it to happen
anymore and was ready to cut the scene
completely but kidman stopped him and
they went ahead
why she wanted to do it for real isn't
very clear but
it's definitely weird look at me
it's not practical sweets are great but
the amount and combinations that will
fairleads and elf
is not what's crazy is that he actually
did eat
all of this and more farrell said he
didn't sleep a lot while filming and was
often totally wired because the amount
of sugar he was consuming
to make it all worse he developed
chronic headaches as well
if what we saw wasn't enough many of the
other weird things he had to eat like
the doctor's cotton balls
even more sugar did you hear that
those were cotton candy can you pass
some maple syrup please
halle berry was preparing to play the
role of an addict in jungle fever but
wasn't sure quite how to go about it so
she wound up
not showering for the full two months of
production
logical we're not too sure but it's
definitely gross the actress admitted
that it was super gross and she did end
up keeping a few parts of her body clean
we can imagine the crew was probably
pretty thankful for that
oh i like her we don't know if we should
be impressed or
totally grossed out all these disgusting
things actors did for roles shows their
commitment to the craft for sure
we can't imagine having to do any of
this stuff for a job
what experience grossed you out the most
[Music]